thank you
okay
we're live streaming now it's now it's
now three o'clock
um welcome everybody to the
infrastructure meeting today second of
May
um firstly
I have apologies and they are from
councilor kit councilor Scout can I have
someone please move we accept those
Grant seconded Evelyn I'll put that all
those in favor
okay we have no Zoom attendees and there
is no public forum today
it takes us to the first item which is
to confirm the minutes from 4th of April
of the obstructure meeting
can I ask a question yeah certainly on
those certainly
obviously the minutes need to
accurately reflect the location
um and I noticed that it's recorded this
haven't been held to hanaki Civic
building
um so can I ask it I mean have we
officially changed the name of this
building because it has always been
recorded as a specific administration
building in the past and I don't want to
debate the merits of the name it's just
the the fact that is that actually the
official meme
who would like to answer
microphone's been given to Michael
through yourself chair um yes it was a
council of
um decision
I think it's about five months ago I'll
need to go back and get the exact date
in relation to that that did have the
official name changed to that particular
name
um no actually it was before this it was
just before this Council
um formed so it was August
uh 2022 that the meeting occurred that
uh officially changed their name to
tianaki and um I think I I reminded
Council some time ago in relation to
apologies for the delay in and acting on
that
um it was through the whole cycle of the
elections but it didn't occur until
about two months ago in relation to the
official change but that was signed off
at the August meeting
kit Series so it could could I just ask
then Michael in terms of official change
in the name
um I mean it was approved by Council and
the name has been changed but what does
official mean in that context is it a
document someplace that's now been
officially changed to hinaki is that the
uh it's very self-tier uh that that
happens through our uh
meeting process in relation to the
council can prove those changes through
the minutes from that perspective
the officials have from staff have
actually enacted that change through
that process we have to obviously go
through the process of changing the
signs and Etc as part of that once it's
um Council has requested that change to
occur okay thank you
right okay
um
so we have the minutes yep thank you
oh you like to talk about the subject
okay no no no
um I just want to note that my apology
isn't noted in the minutes
that I had emailed to both okay
Justin thank you
um Mr Mayor yes just in relation to what
the deputy mayor raised it's my
understanding from the August meeting
the the name of the building would be
ICC Civic building that we were dropping
the admin and that the ewe title would
follow that not preceded so I have
raised that in the last week with the
chief executive and that's an ongoing
discussion
Michael would you like to say yeah three
yourself chair um Mia Clarke we will be
looking into that to make sure that
we've got exactly the right outcome in
relation to that I will refer back to
the minute to make sure that we've got
the right approval in place okay
Grant then Alex
not with respect to that matter so did
you I want to talk about the CCTV yeah I
did yeah I just wondered um because the
the name adoption was part of the wider
Terrier or tipuni Maori language plan
that was adopted by ICC so uh that was
it's not just the name of the building
in isolation there's a whole wider plan
um for how we you know incorporate Maori
language into ICC so I think that would
be really helpful if we had that
document
circulated or added onto the resource
center for our new Council the benefit
of our new councilors I think that's
good for consistency okay that's good um
yeah Grant you've got something about
CCTV yeah just with respect so what
what's the time frame
um for delivery for that project so
we've approved
funding
we're going to be seeing
that
project underway and those tick
everyone's up and running okay it's air
Community safer I got two points of call
um either Aaron Russell or Leslie on the
committee do you know any more on the
committee Leslie I think any type of
year and on the time frame
um look what I'd say is that there's
various different time frames for the
different stages of the project I don't
have those in front of me at the moment
Russell may have them off the top of his
head but I think for the purpose of
today's meeting it might be helpful if
we circulate those
Russell nothing Dan
no
uh Mr Mayor yeah my recall of that
meeting was that um
the the the major CBD stuff would be
done by the end of this year but the
other stuff was very much a staged okay
a stage implementation that it's not all
in one go okay okay Grant legal I'll
Endeavor is chair to the next meeting
amount of time to bring back something
okay and do we have a second uh
Texas until now the adoption of the code
of practice
for subdivision land use and development
for consultation and who would like
speak down Rhiannon
and Russell
so I'm going to speak to the process
around the development of this draft
code of practice and then Russell is
going to speak to the content the
technical content of the document itself
and the intended changes so
um
at present time ICC has a bylaw which
governs how infrastructure must be put
into place by developers when they put
in new subdivisions
and that is governed through a bylaw
process but as the report outlines it's
kind of it is quite an unusual
um structure within New Zealand to use a
bylaw and we have never taken any
enforcement actions under the bylaw
um Southern District Council also has a
bylaw and so um conversations began
about the benefits of working together
to essentially put in place a more
up-to-date code of practice that would
be more flexible and response responsive
to change and would provide a more
consistent experience for developers
many of whom undertake projects both
within the invercargill district and the
southern district
um so the southern district council and
ICC teams have been working over the
previous year or so on this project and
process certain District Council had
actually commenced work earlier and we
have then joined their process and the
technical expertise that they had
gathered
um Our advice is to move to this new
draft code of practice which would be
enforceable under the RMA Provisions in
the district plan as the more
appropriate enforcement mechanism in
order to also then provide those
benefits to the developer Community for
a more consistent response and to enable
more up-to-date
processes so that we can respond to
changing engineering standards changes
within the National Standard which are
expected to come without before too long
and also enable
um
us to be more responsive to the needs of
the developer Community but also
crucially to the needs of Mana Furniture
through retail marama so Terra marimo
were involved towards the end of this
process but unfortunately probably it's
a learning for next time around that
um given the technical nature of this
document
that participation probably came too
late to enable tail Manama to provide
much substantive feedback and we are
placed at the introduction to the
document does provide context around the
importance of considering Teo Maru and
the important things
that we're required to consider under
the treaty obligations
but there's certainly opportunity for
more in-depth analysis and inclusion of
items Within
they code approached itself so moving to
this new structure means that we will be
able to update and keep this document
current more frequently and one of the
benefits of that will mean that we can
complete and continue that ongoing
engagement with tail Manama on this
process
so um I'll probably pass to you Russell
to talk to the technical content of the
document
makes it cheap this is the technical
document that says that air nuts and
bolts for land subdivision
um for some time we've heard from I
guess the Contracting in the Consulting
industry that we have a standard in the
southern district have a standard me
sometimes close but sufficiently
different that they do Make Mistakes by
overlapping we have successfully been
working with the district council
engineering team and have six I guess as
I would see after a long time actually
agreed how we will pull those two
documents and have a common shared basis
and I think that's really what this is
pulling our engineering standards which
to be fair at the end of the day we're
relatively close we didn't have any huge
game changes but some of those small and
minor things we've been able to pull
together and include into one document
which we think will actually be helpful
for both the consultants and the design
work but also the contractors and their
build
some of their future challenges will be
to keep that agreement together as we go
forward but I think for this document it
actually shows that we've been able to
have
um a document which we can start it will
lead into our I guess our work practices
and it will actually help going forward
to align
um wherever the three Waters path takes
us so that we actually have similar
standards across it
this the next wave of consultation
that's planned will actually give us an
opportunity to review and make sure what
we've got actually works but really what
we're seeing in this document is our
current practices pulled together
and making sure that it aligns and is
helpful
and um sorry sheriff I could make one
last Point following Russell's comments
um Southend District Council is
reviewing this topic tomorrow at their
meeting
um just from a procedural point of view
um I'd like to propose a change to
recommendation eight just to deal with
the circumstance we have no reason to
think it might happen at this point but
if for some reason they did not adopt
the code of practice then we would just
need the hearing panel to hear only the
ICC code so just like to propose a
change to the word in which I've given
to malavika
foreign
yes the change to eight to the structure
of the hearing panel
okay because the structure of the
hearing panel is actually actually in
seven
yes you're right sure it could ease it
could be added to either or oh okay
right right and can you just briefly
explain before we open up the floor
um the role of the the three delegates
that that we uh kind of Chase is it and
the amount of meetings and
so on so we anticipate there would be
one round of hearings just as for any
normal consultation that we run
um the only difference in this case is
that it is a joint hearing panel with
Southern District Council
um we have had pre-engagement with the
developer Community feedback was
positive on there being one
one code that would be across the region
um we anticipate that submissions are
likely to come from that Technical
Community there shouldn't be too many in
I would anticipate it would be one
meeting of a couple of hours in the say
SDC do go ahead um that panel selects
their own chair from themselves yes that
would okay no excellent I'm gonna open
up the floor questions now we're going
to start with
nobody's in Tom then Leslie so just some
observations about this paper it seems
to me it's coming into force with within
two months time which is a very fast
pace
um it also talks about South and wide
where in fact there's no mention of Gaul
in that in that equation
um
and it also talks about the new code of
practice format means that the code of
practice can be updated more frequently
in the future I'm not sure how updating
things frequently in the future gives
developers any certainty
and it seems to me from what we've heard
today from staff that te awamarama
didn't have enough time to input and I
guess I'd be concerned if they
subsequently have been put after the
first of July that might change the
balance or the picture of what the code
of practice is actually saying for those
developers and the whole goal of this is
to have a unified approach ideally
across all three councils so I don't
know why Gore's not in this picture at
the stage so I'll just stop there um
Rhiannon is there any reason why Gore
may not
Gore was not resourced to take part in
this process at this point it wasn't a
priority for them
um so it was agreed by the leadership
and the executive leadership at Council
and at SDC that it brought real benefits
and we would work towards this
um speaking to the matter of the the
urgency and the time frame
um the technical staff have been working
on this for quite a while the reason for
the consultation period is that our
bylaw is due to expire at the end of
June beyond that point Council will not
have any guidance
that is enforceable for
um developers so it is important that we
have in place guide guidelines so that's
why the three options are outlined
um
and that's why the
um the time frame
okay thank you Tom
mummy in question was about Gore chair
so that's been answered but I just
wonder there's a reason why in um
recommendation six and seven were
referred to as invercargill District
Council right on City Council
I think that is just purely my error
that I had written the words District
Council too many times and then so
that's my area we should change that
from the IDC
food to the ICC
thanks thanks John uh Leslie just a
point to that sorry Mr chair and number
six that is corrected as the invocabul
city district plan that's the Resource
Management District plan document but
you're quite correct in terms of number
seven
and that has been corrected right
uh Leslie then Alan thanks Mr chair just
for a bit of historic context that other
councilors won't be aware of in my first
term on Council I was part of the shared
services committee that at that time
included ourselves Southland district
and Gore District this was one of the
topics on the agenda of that committee
um which ceased to exist sometime during
my second term on Council
um I'm I'm actually very pleased to see
it go forward I did understand that Gore
wasn't able to Resource the involvement
but that South London invercargill were
able to go ahead and
I've I've read
um
what is so far the feedback from the
pre-engagement with the developers
that's pretty much what we were being
told
um to that shared services committee as
well I would think that it would be a
very welcome new plan and I'm looking
forward to the consultation on it
Ellen
that's the district council and the city
council both the doctors can you see a
time when you may actually sort of have
a one Southern Department
in the same the employers of the South
and the Macau city council could perhaps
do District work and vice versa which
means that you you've got more people
more personality utilization of
resources yeah is it is it the long-term
plan going forward which is what this is
just talking about there basically as
well I would refer that to the chief
executive
thank you through yourself chair look
we're always looking for opportunities
to work with our partnering councils
across the region on where we can
maximize shared resources from that
perspective this particular item has not
been discussed at length in relation to
what that means in the near future but
it's always something we can have
further discussions on
Peggy Russell
I think this is also about making sure
our suppliers only have to stock one or
the agreed components and also the
design teams know one purpose so rather
than having an invercargill specific or
particular Trend or like it's actually
some of this is the economy the scale
that we're looking to pick up on the way
past and to be fair
avoid some of those costly mistakes that
we've seen at times from contractors
where they've actually done work to the
wrong stand in the wrong place and have
to have corrected it so this is quite a
logical piece of
gathering together and as I said
wrestling between the technical teams to
get an agreed level one position
Alex
thank you Mr chair how much of this
bylaw will be captured or is proposed to
be captured when the mefe transition
transitions us sorry into the new
National planning framework
so um this code of practice absorbed
will replace the bylaw so there won't be
a bylaw if we proceed down this path and
as to that question of what what it
would mean during the transition process
we probably can't answer that question
at this point because we don't have
enough information yet on what that
reform process might look like but it
does reflect the National Standard
um so there is no reason to believe that
it wouldn't be taken forward
just I think
um
I've obviously because I won the
governance of tamarama here to talk to
them about this and got a little bit of
feedback about how it looks now which is
not to preempt any submissions they may
make under the consultation process as
is normal as is their right however what
I the the one question that I really did
have is if we revoke the bylaw are we
going to have any enforcement
professions at all within this and if so
where will they sit how much weight will
they have
so we will have enforcement Provisions
under the district plan and the resource
management act and I might refer to
Michael Morris if that's okay to give
more detail on the enforcement mechanism
mechanisms
thank you and to you Mr chair so
the win provision is incorporated into a
district plan uh it is an offense to do
something contrary to the district plan
under the resource management act which
is punishable by the by an infringement
fine or in a serious case prosecution
um so the resource management act itself
makes it an offense to do something
contrary to a district plan so if the
code of practice is an incorporated
document
into their District plan then that's the
enforcement mechanism through our
resource management team
rather than trying to do a bylaw
prosecution which is the only way you
can enforce a bylaw there is no
infringement fines at the moment
you thank you for that and I'm further
to that just in terms of we're talking
about synergies
um as we know environment Southland at
the moment is going through things like
paying change to itai and all that sort
of thing how much discussion has been
had with them about how well this
measures with the proposed changes that
they're doing or is this one of the
supplemental changes we we may have to
make
uh post implementation of this code of
practice
so environment safe and we're invited to
participate in the pre-engagement
process and I'm sorry I can't recall
about any specific feedback that they
had at this point
um I might Russell you might have
further comment to make but
um my understanding is that the
alignment is more at the district plan
level rather than the way to practice
itself certainly at land subdivision
which is which is a process that
councils do drive I guess perhaps a wee
bit more to your first question is that
when someone seeks a sub a land
subdivision
they apply for resource consent and
within that resource consent will be
that you'll actually have to develop
your engineering plans to a code of
practice and for for the developer they
need to meet that those requirements to
get their land title and that's I guess
their greatest opportunity to make sure
that they comply with their rules and
that is so they can't get title they
can't see how they start selling their
subdivision so we have quite a power
over I guess
developers to make sure they comply with
what they're required to do so so it's
quite a powerful document sitting inside
the district plan
okay
um
yeah two things I I'm not sure I've got
a straight answer on this stuff so just
listening to the discussion there just
like some clarification it seems to me
that
um
that they didn't have time to fully
participate
and may make some contributions through
the Consulting process and may also
activate the
um frequent updates provision that now
comes with the code of practice which
isn't there with a bylaw and I just
wonder whether we've got that all that
right I mean given that we fund that
organizational part funded and the
significance of its advice to us that we
just seem to be catching up with that at
some later today so that's an
observation I guess and just what I've
heard too about environment itself and
not being involved the recent climate
events in the North Island have said
that have shown it's clearly that
Regional councils need to be involved
with these sorts of issues around
subdivisions and where they are and the
nature of how they're developing and to
have them not in there along with TR
marima and along with Gore doesn't seem
to be a good way forward for developers
I wouldn't have thought
we'll just have an evolving landscape
for them that will keep changing until
we get to a certain point
so as much as I'd like things to be in
place by the first of July I am
wondering whether we should buy a source
a bit more time to get this right at the
first opportunity well I think before
Darren um I think we have to do it we
have to have something in place bye
yes legally
yeah
um the comment that I'd like to make is
the this this process has been um going
on I think for well over 18 months um
possibly even longer that it first came
um to the elt uh I agree with the the
comments being made from the mayor that
we want to take as as Regional and as
joined up process as we possibly can
when we're doing this work however what
I'd say is that there's always uh the
opportunity to start somewhere
um and although we haven't perhaps been
able to join up everybody that we would
ideally like to
um being able to join up ICC and SDC as
the two larger councils is a significant
step forward and one that the team have
on from both councils have had to work
really really hard to get us to the
stage that we are at at the moment
um so I'd really like to see us be able
to take that forward and then continue
to build on it moving forward
um as far as the Regional Council goes
there is a hierarchical process anyway
where a lot of what we put in place as
giving effect to the regional rules
which effectually essentially give
effect to the National policy statements
as well so there's no great difference
in there it would be advantageous to
have had them more engaged with
pre-consultation
um it's good that we've been working
with Southland District councils
actually goes back to before we started
to do the last District plan review that
we tried to to get everybody together to
to
restructure in this way
um Gaul went their own way with uh like
a licensing and and the district Road
plan so it's just south and invercargill
there's nothing new in there
in both environments South and Antelope
will have the opportunity and probably
having a bit more of a heads up we'll be
able to plan time-wise around being able
to submit in through this consultative
process
um it's been something that from a
customer perspective people have been
looking for for some time because you
will have somebody doing something on
one side of a road that isn't allowed on
the other side of the road and this
would allow a great deal more clarity
yeah it would be nice if we could have
the the same around
um
uh gold district but that actually isn't
our neighbor and we're surrounded by
Southland District so from a city's
perspective that's a good way of tying
things up I'll not express any opinions
further than that because I'm keeping an
open mind for the consultative process
Alan
uh yeah likewise I'll give you an open
mind too but it seems like a very
positive thing to me yeah moving forward
because there has been a lot of issues
in the past between the different ways
of getting different kinds of different
things I think it's a an extremely
positive start okay I think that's good
I just one final question from the chair
and that's just a bit left field will
this mean
a consistent interpretation of the
billing code between both councils
when you come to build things not the
building code no no it's not it's not
but when you do these consistent
subdivisions
I'm just saying you know that's all good
it is definitely different it is
different but I know I know I mean if we
want to be consistent with one side of
the of the fence
uh shouldn't building codes be
consistent foreign
that our teams can work together and
have some common discussions around
issues hopefully the closer we move
towards an alignment on broader issues
as well yeah that's okay I just thought
I'd check that in there okay well the
way I'm going to take these
recommendations is one to seven first
before we
choose the delegates okay it's kind of
someone move I'll move
recommendations one to seven secondary
thank you Leslie I'll put those
recommendations one to seven dollars in
favor
aye against uh Carey now I've got an
eight we need three delegates
um do we have a problem volunteers got
Darren
uh Ria
pania Trish
that's
four we've got four we need three plus
one Alterna
that's four which is cool okay so who
but who if we who are the three that go
on even though you're gonna last down
well through YouTube really it's good
that those that are going onto the panel
have some understanding of resource
management
yeah yeah but uh we still need obviously
the alternate is for when someone's
unavailable
um so we do need three I guess am I
getting is that right Rhiannon we need
three
main ones and an alternate
perhaps since we don't have the date
the date to leave it
as well
if that suits uh if we can include that
in there then
I'm gonna someone can someone move
recommendation thank you Evelyn seconded
Grant I'm gonna put that all those in
favor
thank you for that
takes us now to waste net Reserves
now this I I requested this just as a
preamp for our May 15th meeting of
wastenet it's coming up and uh I guess
in mind was a request from this Council
regarding wanting to spend money on
education and various things that we
could apply to wasting it for they have
to wasting a council has to approve the
distribution of funds so
um
but at the moment we don't have any
costings at all on our request do we
Aaron
um so I'm I'm happy to speak to the
report um and just before we get into
the detail I just do want to make an
apology and that I may have gotten us a
little um excited in error around the
figures which was my mistake from the
team
um the the total waste net reserves are
actually forecast at year end to be 1.33
across all three councils of which ICC
share is then 55 potentially or 730 000
apologies I made the error the other way
not in our favor apologies for that so
the potential ICC share would be 730 000
uh and and that's a assuming um that we
had that agreement out of wastenet to
distribute those funds okay this is
realizing this this sits there and then
when reading the document further
wastenet has an annual income of around
750. that's yeah so this this gets
replenished so this is residual from uh
money's not spent okay so
um I think the other piece that we we've
discussed recently
um that's just worth clarification is
that although the recycle processing
contract sits outside of the wasternet
agreement and that ICC holds that
relationship directly with recycle South
that the waste education
component I guess of of the waste agenda
still sits with wastenet and is still
funded by the three councils and that's
because much of that waste education
agenda is around what people put in
their curbside bins and that that's
still a joint Arrangement between the
three Southland councils
okay I'm gonna open up the floor to any
questions regarding the report
noting that um there will be a report
back from the May 15 meeting at wastenet
for further questions uh Mr Mayor yep um
when I read through this document it's
very similar stuff that we've had for
probably the last 10 years
a sad indictment on this Council and
other councils that we haven't got onto
this educational stuff
and I'm not picking on anybody in
particular I've been party to it as well
um but it needs to happen it needs to
happen quickly
um the sort of um the graphics we've got
going through there are nice but they're
not the core issues
um the core issue for me is on um
it's on page 251 aboard books
um and what the vision is by 2035 or
residents and businesses will have a
better understanding of waste management
and a circular economy it does not take
eight years to educate the people on
wasting it about Recycling and we've got
to do way way more than that and much
much quicker so certainly from my
Pursuit we need to get our hands on our
share of that waste net money and employ
a couple of Education officers that go
around the schools and start to excite
people about recycling because our
national stats are not good I guess the
other issue is we've got Gore missing
out of this equation again and I
appreciate that Keith is a chair and he
seems to have an enthusiasm to bring us
back into the fall but then they're not
mentioned in there either
and it seems it seems to me that we're
still taking the approach we took 10
years ago that until we've educated the
community we won't do any enforcement
action and I'd like to like to have some
peace of mind that we will start doing
enforcement action for those people that
continually
um do the wrong thing and the last thing
I've comment I make is that that one
other large piece is missing in this
whole document is the issue of glass
we don't have any any sort of
determination when we deal with that we
flog both ways on that issue so at the
moment if you put glass into a recycling
bin it destroys all the other Recycling
and it makes it hard to opt in on sell
it if you put it in your normal waste
basket it just increases the weight
that's going to landfill and that just
increases the cost of everybody so
um I'd like to think this paper or a
subsequent paper that comes back from
your waste net group identifies what we
need to do and do quickly on the issue
of glass
I appreciate it and I can't advance to
me and that that the glass thing is work
and process and as chair I can I can
back that up so Trish
um just with regard to the education
program
um at the moment the New Zealand
equipment has been refreshed it's a very
opportune time to get that
so they could use it as part of their
context for learning across the
curriculum I would suggest that we get
onto that very fast and I agree that we
need to run
um the
Recycled process similar we don't need
to wait till the education when to
finish
um okay Grant
it just
um a couple of things the objectives
they don't seem to be too miserable
um
and it's a little bit to the mere's
point around you know 2035 I think we
need to be much tighter on what we're
actually trying to achieve like I've
said the objective was to reduce waste
by 20 percent
then you can measure that's a very
specific outcome around people's
behavior it's a very
tangible miserable benefit around the
reduction of cost so you know I think
this paper needs to be much tighter in
terms of the objectives we're trying to
achieve in the time frames needs to be
much shorter and the other point I
question or ask to understand is you
know the programs that are listed out as
tools how effective are those programs
so what's the effectiveness of this
um
you know
having older children but you know
digital you know kids are all over
digital stuff
um I'd like to see something that's
really enables kids to connect really
strongly with a program that fits into
the way they live their lives which is
which is in front of this you know on
screens and so I think we need to sort
of
um have a much more robust plane around
us if we really want to be successful in
terms of reducing waste and getting a
benefit for our community in in saving
money
thank you Evelyn
um yes I looked at the tolls one as well
and I didn't really there's something
that's really heavy at the younger age
group which is the ways free wander and
things like that
um
I'll just question how we reach out to
the teenagers but
um there's wiser Minds than than mine I
don't have a teenager living in the
house so I've lost track of how we
communicate at that level but
um I did want to highlight something
about the local businesses because I've
won
um
go into miter 10 and see that they have
collection points for different
um streams of waste there and I wonder
if we should be highlighting those
things a bit more
um I mean it's
they have it but how much do people know
and if people are not able to travel to
those places are they missing out on the
place where they can take the batteries
back or they can take the um beer
potting materials back you know all
those sorts of things I believe they
take light bulbs as well am I wrong
I don't know but you raised a valid
point that we in our education program
and I've got to agree with the mayor
that in 2012 when I was on Race net we
were sitting here talking about the same
thing
um so groundhog day seems to be the the
way but what Evelyn raised is that we
can't assume that people know anything
and our our campaigning needs to be
quite blunt and state the obvious and
people will learn so look you've got to
trust me on this one as chair I'm quite
passionate about this and I'm not going
to let it slip okay uh next is Alex
uh thank you Mr chair
um tell Taco what uh councilor dumity
has said
um I think that we really need to press
on wastenet that they uh
ideate around what kind of kpi
deliverables or miserable goals that we
could look at because like Hebrew
rightly said if we reduce waste we also
reduce cost to The Entity and therefore
cost to the ratepayer
um also agree with you in that uh I
agree with Evelyn that
um publicizing some of those private
depositories would be great as well
um and things like I know a lot of
people that I know are trying to get rid
of the E-Waste where can you even take
that
can you dispose of batteries or things
that are potentially toxic to land I
think we really need to get you know we
can use our own channels to publicize
that as well rather than just relying on
wife's need to do all the heavy lifting
for us
um campaigns like this is there's some
good bones in this um Communications
strategy
but unless we see what kind of budget
split our money is going towards
as a marketing professional I've got no
idea how to quantify what that campaign
is actually going to look like like if I
had numbers in front of me knowing how
much is being pushed into it and I
haven't knowing how much time is being
pushed into it you'd be able to have a
relative idea of how much impact that's
going to have but because we don't have
any of that information it's impossible
so I invite the report post to your
meeting
um cheer great okay pania I just want to
agree with the mere around glass and
what he said as well at Germany
um
I want to say that really does let the
measures it's not measurable here I'm
really struggling uh Ajit does a really
great
um I mean for example we have the order
healthy school lunches program and I
know that
some of them actually will pick up the
waste and actually measure it
and so and look at it to see how they
can reduce it
you know with the schools so I'm just
saying you know having you know being
able to see and how they measure it is
really important to me okay
right look one one further thing is that
following on from what that Alex said is
that we can only really move forward if
we if we actually know
where we currently are and where we want
to be because currently figures would
say in this report it says 650 kilograms
per capita for the year ending June 2022
yet our own
performance
uh report
uh dated 30 June 2022 for ICC States
figure of 726 kgs now this there is no
consistency there so we don't know
whether we're going up down sideways and
unless if that the worst thing is if
that uh
financial report from June in our
performance report is wrong we overrated
so look at this we just need to get
these figures correct
and then we can do some measuring so
it's been valuable discussion and we
just need to keep this moving so if you
don't see anything happening keep
reminding me okay
right
so we've got three recommendations
there
we're going to receive the report
note the ICC share is 55 of 1.3 million
is
you've crunched that out
and
note the attached education enforcement
enforcement summary prepared for the
15th of May
okay can I have someone move that please
uh Alan seconded partner put the
motional and some favor
aye hence that has carried takes us on
to the activities report
just a point of water here we had a
great deal of discussion in the last 10
minutes about the delivery framework
timetable and we've just approved that
to go forward to wasting it and I don't
know why we did that
because there was quite a bit of
discussion here about the time frame of
2035 which is 12 years away
a lot of my colleague raised issue about
no measures here anyway just a whole lot
of ideals
um no deliverables if we put that
through as a major stakeholder in this
game that's what we'll end up with at
the end of the day and we'll start with
nothing to start with and we'll go on a
journey while we've been for the last 12
years since ironic we're talking about
another 12-year time frame and we'll end
up here 12 years from now discussing now
the journey
um
look as chair I would the right things I
see working
is that we've approved this to go to
wastenet on the 15th of May I will ask
for approval of a these these monies
from Wasteland bring it back to this
Council
with our either our media people or
wherever and we approve a budget we may
not want to spend all that 730 000 on
education but that's where it starts we
have to bring that back
and I see that as moving forward
okay
so uh Mr chair are you then saying once
it is brought back we would have a
further discussion about the dates we
would put in the measurements we would
put on I think I think so I talked to at
least before and and one thing is that
we've got to give our Communications
people or whoever's doing this a budget
and then around that budget around that
will be time frames and obviously some
measurables but it's not just a this is
not just a sort of a one-off hit
campaign we need some frequency so that
people are constantly reminded and
following on from what Evelyn said we
need to have a place people can go to
that says where the battery drop-off
point is all this stuff so you're just
living it
um look I just caution around whether or
not we're talking about providing
feedback into to wastenet and I'll be
honest the normal path would be for this
paper to go to wastenet and then come
back to the councils we we have
accommodated a request for it to come
slightly in Reverse in this instance
um but at this stage that that education
component is still jointly held by
wastenet
um I don't know whether what we're
talking about here is saying we wouldn't
hold that education component with
wastenet in the future so I guess I'd
just at this stage we are doing it
jointly through wastenet and we had a
recent discussion around whether or not
governance should continue to have a
wastenet governance group or whether or
not the waste net staff members should
report into each individual Council and
it was resolved that at this stage that
the wastenet governance group at this
stage wanted to continue in you so
that's the direction that officers are
continuing to move in at this stage
unless we I guess get a direction
otherwise
okay just before I take you know Allison
Evelyn look
we need to take control of this and
that's why I don't want to leave it with
waste we need to get the monies approved
and bring it back to this Council
if SDC want to come on board we can talk
to them about a joint campaign they're
recycling but if we don't do it
ourselves and we leave it to waste net
which is
and it isn't going to happen sorry and
and I guess this Council will have to
endorse that but sorry and I just can't
see it happening underway snap I just
can't see the mechanism of an education
system it's failed before
um but if this Council does it because
we are we we actually hold the
um the contract with East with Southland
disabilities do you see any problem with
that
foreign
look what I would say is that the best
thing that you can give staff to be able
to take something forward is consistency
um one of the the really great things
from a staff perspective that's happened
recently is that it's nationally
mandated now around what recyclables
should be collected staff were really
struggling to get a strong education
message out previously because we were
struggling to get agreement around the
table around even between us our
contractors our Governors around what we
should be accepting for recycling and
what we shouldn't and therefore it's
really hard to go out with an education
campaign if we can't agree amongst
ourselves now we've got a really strong
guidance rightly or wrongly whether we
agree with it or not government's now
mandated what we should collect so now
staff have got a really strong basis to
go forward and roll out that that
education message and push that out
through the community
I'd suggest giving that a chance before
we change the direction again
right we've got Alex Evelyn Grant and
Trish
can I can I go last
um so I think where I met with this is
that what
it was I think
Carol city has an obligation to reduce
the amount of waste it
puts into the system if that means that
we use
some of the money that has been
accumulated that is considered to be the
cities
share so to speak
um to push certain messages I don't see
that as a bad thing as long as they're
just not inconsistent with whatever the
collective is doing so if we choose to
make
I don't know July
your e
um rubbish your E-Waste you know I mean
I could give them a whole lot from my
place and I'm sure I'm not the only one
because I don't know what to do with it
and it just sits there if we made that a
target for the month of July would we
see a difference in what you know and
then two months later it's your
batteries or your paint cans or whatever
it is I don't see the negative side of
doing that because it's just really
reinforcing other messages but putting
invercargills spin on it and hopefully
reducing our impact on the environment
and their cost to the ratepayers
yeah look
um
to me I think there's a couple of
options and I agree with Evelyn you know
it's our responsibility as a city maybe
it's signaling in my mind that we need
to re-look at the contract we have with
wastenet and whether they are
responsible for education or we are but
make it really clear within there and
then if they are then it's measurable
against the contract
that can be taught those points of
Vellum they can be raised on the 15th
yeah but at the end of the day and it's
Evelyn's point you know add duty is to
make sure air city has a very healthy
relationship with waste in terms of how
we reuse and recycle and in you know
efficiently and effectively working with
air resources so you know I think that
contract needs to be reviewed so just to
clarify it it's not a contract that we
hold with wastenet
um what it is is a collaboration between
the councils it's a joint venture
um and we have an agreement to work
collectively together
um so sorry so that so there's no
defining sort of what the purpose of
that is and what the outcomes are and
how miserable that is and there are no
performance pieces in it there is an
agreement but I wouldn't say that there
are strong performance measures within
that agreement I'd agree
um what I would say though is that the
ICC holds the staff for wastenet which
means that those staff are appointed by
ICC and then they are jointly funded by
the other councils when we talk about
doing out some something outside of
waste net I guess I question are we
talking about appointing ICC a dedicated
staff because at the moment the waste
staff that we have are waste net staff
so that becomes then a question of Are
We telling you know we're going to waste
net and saying we want to take some of
those staff out of waste net it does
become I guess I would question what
council is seeking there yeah
I think it's pretty clear what the
council's seeking is they want to be
outcome from waste management and so
you know I think you pull that back and
you say right we need to re re-look at
how we do this
we know where we want to get to we put
some Miserables on it and some outcomes
and then we determine what that
agreement or collaboration or whatever
we want to call it looks like
but the reality is that all the councils
will have the same issue and challenge
you know they're all wanting to do this
as you've pointed out as central
government you know I've got some pretty
hard measures around it but it's not
only that it's this is the best way for
free community so I I've got some
suggestions I guess that I'll put before
wastenet around how we can do this
better what I would say is that to date
um you know no disrespect to the people
involved but wastenet is generally an
officer level position
um and is then dealt with at a at a
senior level by group managers
um like myself and similar for other
councils at a group manager level we've
obviously got competing priorities and
the amount of time that I give to waste
isn't really sufficient to I think move
us in the direction and at the pace that
council is seeking so what we'll be
discussing at the way snap meeting on
the 15th is whether or not we need an
additional resource in the wastenet
space that gives the waste net
governance group the ability to have
somebody at a management level to
interact with and drive this forward at
a greater Pace perhaps than what group
managers have been able to drive this
forward to date yeah I I concern with
that is what Ben did you know I think we
need to pull this thing apart and look
at it and establish where we want to get
to and then design a program approach
that gets us there no I think we made a
point and it's very valid before I go to
Trish I'm going to jump to the chief
executive thank you through yourself
chair I just wanted to touch on the
point about the agreement I think it is
uh fair to say that before you touch on
any processes in relation to wasting it
would be fair that you need to have a
look and understand what the agreement
is in place in relation to westnet I'll
look to make sure that that is available
via the resource center so the council
has access to that the other aspect is
we also have an Administration contract
and place to wastenet for our accounting
and financial services from that
perspective so that needs to be taken
into account as well I'll see if we can
make that available what we can
onto the resource center but I think if
you have a look at that that would um
clarify some questions I think the
question around the advertising is a key
one and that is within that agreement so
it does actually stipulate that the
advertising is included within there and
that's why they're collecting some funds
from the councils to be able to provide
for advertising from that perspective so
it is part of that agreement
that full Suite of documents will go to
the meeting on the 15th and then we'll
come to council as part of the minutes
and yeah it's a waste me to run very
effective
in programs
um going back you know with East staff
computers on various things they've done
some particularly good things and I just
think perhaps rather than tinger with
the whole thing we give clear Direction
about where we want to be and see if we
can Implement with theme what it is we
want to achieve
I'm sorry guys I I seen the photograph
that was taken
um I'm not sure who received it but it
was a photo of a dump from a city
collection of yellow bins dumped at the
uh
platform at Southern disabilities and it
was appalling
it you would think it was out of the
Redmond yeah it was living it was
breathing it was it was disgusting and
and that's where we've got to
unfortunately at the moment and if we've
evolved to that then this is why the
urgency this is not just about
fine-tuning something this is this is
something far greater than that because
it's not working
it is it is just being abused and that's
why I mean I'm quite Keen to get into
enforcement but you know obviously
education comes between before
enforcement
okay we've got Alex do you want to go
last because the mayor's gonna speak oh
sorry yeah then Alex wants the wants to
be last yeah
look if I'm honest I still have some
concerns about us being reliant on waste
net delivery
um the current structure of the wastenet
group is that the chair Deputy chair are
both from Gore and the Administration
has run into core as well
you don't have to be a rocket scientist
to know what Gore's done on recycling in
the last four years it's diabolical
really is so um and I agree with Grant
we should start at the other end and
decide what we want as a council unpick
our current relationship and go
backwards and decide What mechanisms we
need to be able to deliver that and if
it turns out that it's waste net and as
Trish says they've done some good work
in the past that's fine if it's not then
we should be brave enough to go alone
because that's what we did with the
contract
can't sit back for another 12 years the
latest report to come out of that
National report created the South as the
worst recycling District in the country
okay one thing I'll just jump in and say
is that that wastenet has the contracts
with the um collection people that
selected all the three so there's there
is some
um
commonality there between between that
and that's where wasting it sits over it
also has the contract with a B lime for
the landfill and it would be sort of I
think a step back once if we all had
separate contracts but
but look you know as as adults we should
be able to sort this out it doesn't seem
to me that strong so uh last one is Alex
yay thank you this is the last Mr chair
except for the cheers closing comments
um
a few things uh Aaron is Right obviously
but just to reinforce that
um it has been a really long time coming
for the national framework of what is
actually what the government actually
determined what is actually going to be
recyclable what we need to collect what
we don't need to collect what we need to
provide for it's been a really long time
to get there and there's no point
educating and changing
human behaviors
only to just have to re-educate again
so it's it makes sense why there's been
a reduction in that education space now
that we've got that settled I would
expect us to double down on
the education component within wastenet
as you say they've done great things
before but rather than extricate funding
out of it shouldn't we be feeding it to
be able to amplify
it doesn't make sense that we're saying
on one hand actually we understand that
this is councilor Derby a regional issue
everybody else is going to be
replicating and duplicating the same
resources for the same purpose for the
exact same reason that we just passed
this code in the previous paper
everything is better an economy of scale
if we can work together it's been proven
that wastenet has worked together well
worked well on this particular issue
before
um
yanking it out and bringing it in-house
when we've got the team members that
already that are practically already
here in the building anyway just seems
like we're trying to reinvent the wheel
rather than just tightening what our
expectations and its accountability is
up on the framework that we already have
working with our partners
um
the chi is really quite right there's
collegiality between the fact that the
recyclables collection sits there the
contract with baby lion sits there the
educate the only thing that doesn't is
the contract with recycle South I think
to pull
yet another piece from that will be a
bit of a slap in the face to our
partners
um
I really definitely understand the point
that we need to tighten the reins we
need to put in some kpis some really
clear outcomes and we need to make sure
that we're funding it to be able to get
the outcomes that we're looking for but
I also think that we've given some
pretty clear uh
indication today to our people that sit
on the waste net that we're actually
looking for that advocacy we want him to
go to that table and say we are looking
for goals and we're looking for clear
kpis and we're looking for Clear
outcomes Within These time frames and I
think we need to trust him to go forward
to do that and then see what comes out
then
you know perhaps have a look at if if
that hasn't aligned with what we're what
we're looking for and if it doesn't then
we you know look at look at Plan B but I
think we need to give it a shot first
right just one comment we uh wasting it
um I had a visit
to a b lime yesterday you know we had a
look at the landfill and we got a tour
and it's very impressive we're very
lucky to have a grade one land for we
are so lucky
um compared to the rest of the country
because they are like gold and put one
in normally they occupy people fill in a
valley luckily we are filling in a hill
that's been taken out with um with lime
so one of the things we talked about
various issues with the landfill with
the landfill owners and one thing I'll
just one thing that got raised was
lithium batteries and the danger they
are to the landfill
when the big heavy Vehicles drive over
them they explode and create fires and a
Landfill fire
is a very horrible thing because it's
self-containing with the methane that's
there the Plastics and they're very very
hard to put out and and once the
landfill is on fire it can receive no
more waste and hence then we would cease
sending any waste then and that would
continue to pile up so getting to the
point
um well they raised this with wastenet
the issue of batteries being not you
know being excluded and we have not
heard anything about it apparently
wasting it know about it but
we have not been told so here we are
waiting on something to come back to us
and
it it's not happening in Lanham they
have banned batteries
from going in either been Iran recycled
South about what they do with batteries
they go through the recycling thing
and they had
no idea what everyone was saying about
that and they just go straight to waste
so there's a lot of just there's a lot
of misunderstanding out there what can
happen and we need that to be able to
get above it and simple things like that
but that landfire thing is very real
and we just need to work better with
obviously our contractors If they raise
something then that's what wastenet's
for is to address it and uh that's just
one example so
um we'll move forward on that but what I
would say just is that we we have been
I've been in discussion with AV lime
around that and one of the concerns that
we have is that we we all need to work
together as an industry around what the
solution is in that space
um because there isn't an alternative on
what to do with them at this point in
time so a b line haven't said to us that
they would like us to go to that step or
haven't said to me they'd like us to go
to that step to ban them simply because
they're acknowledging that there isn't
that alternative at this time but some
of those difficult issues that we need
to Grapple with as an industry
right but apparently that um
it is a very serious issue and um
it just needs to happen it does it just
does so
um right the recommendations are
they've been done I wanted to respond
ah point of order thanks Zach go on
Groundhog Day you did right we're going
back over it again
so just to the final thing look
I like to hear from staff that we've got
a clear picture from government now look
we've had a clip position on glass for I
don't know longer than I've been in this
place which is four or five years we're
only one of three councils in the
country and there are 50 53 that
actually recycle glass in the
appropriate way we've just sat on our
hands forever
the problem's been too hard
um if we might worry is that we get into
a waste net Coalition again that with
that
delivery framework timetable that will
all agree and feel happy about and no
outcomes for the next 12 years and we'll
just do a lot of fluffy things and
nothing will change
so the history has taught me with um
with wastenet that we only get good
results when we do it ourselves now it
makes no difference I heard what Alex
had to say but it makes no difference if
we've got one educational officer or two
and Council District's got one or two
and Gore's got half an educational one
or whether they're all in the same team
it's still a piece of work that needs to
be done and if we don't grab hold of our
piece of work we'll be dependent on
others and those others do not have good
track records
an available Point Alex obviously you
always seem to have the last thanks
I just wanted to um actually created the
mere
if we
stretched that resource from a regional
uh cooperative
that would that gets the economy of
scale duplication of resources what
makes you think that we on our own can
do it better with less money well two
things in response to that
if you have um
you don't share teachers at school if
you want to get a message across at
school about anything that goes through
the education system you need depending
on how many teachers how many students
you need to have you you have a ratio so
if our ratio for Waste net is that we
need in the next two or three years to
have four or five Educators running
around our wider District doing the work
it makes no difference with those five
are two to the city and two to the
district one to go or five to wasting it
it's still the amount of work that gets
done what breaking it up does it gives
us control to make sure that we get the
delivery the other end because when
we've got all our resource sitting in
waste it all controlled by Gore every
single function of vital record and for
the last four or five years they've put
everything to landfill like everything
Plastics the lot and that doesn't give
me any confidence going forward that
we're going to get a sudden change of
heart there
I'm sorry I guess if you want to get
deliverables you've got to have control
if you don't then you're subject to
other people's view of the world right
yeah I think we're gonna we're gonna end
it's it's going to be chopped but the
chair will have the last say that
that are you okay
these questions will be asked a place
where waste net on the 15th
and if there are no answers on how and
when this will be delivered
in the next month they'll be saying are
we asking the question about why we're
in this and that question should be able
to be answered positively next Wednesday
sorry they're on the on the peptide we
have faith in you too so are you saying
you're reporting back to this next
infrastructure committee
yeah yeah I might say that yeah
yeah like a good idea
as long as Silence of GM is able to
the only other thing I'd add is that um
rangi Can report back on how he feels
that meeting went
um but there was a a paper that went to
the first meeting of wastenet that spoke
about I guess concerns that have been in
place for some time around whether or
not we get
um the the whether each council is
comfortable only being represented by a
subset of of two councilors of each or
whether or not those The Joint contracts
and the staff that a wastenet should
report into the individual councils
Instead at this stage the the waste net
group was resolved not to take forward a
review that staff had proposed of
wastenet and whether or not those
arrangements were appropriate what I'd
say is that ICC obviously has the
ability if they would like to initiate
that review independently that is
something that we could look to do if
you feel that you're not getting the
right outcomes out of wastenet
um it's just would would then be funded
by ICC because at this stage wastenet
have chosen not to to do that review but
that that is an option for ICC if they
wish to do so can I suggest Mr chair
that perhaps in the paper that comes
back to next infrastructure that that
option is one of the
one of the paragraphs on that paper for
us to consider
that sounds good I appreciate you guys
talking about the subject that's very
dear to me and the ideas
that's great okay we've got the
activities report now and same for you
who's doing that Aaron me Russell no no
Russell is still there but I'll take
this one the the only point that I'd
like to highlight before I open for
questions is just around the new road
maintenance contract that contract
um is our largest operational contract
for Council it will go out for a
potential term of seven years of five
plus two
um and that we will be out to Market
with that one next week
for a period of six weeks
okay questions regarding the activities
report
there's the reports received okay it's
received
thank you Leslie and before I put that
motion
um and I just attended
okay and there's Tinder but what I'm
going to do is rather actually talk
about the inactivity report
which is um the roadworks and D Street
with the pipes now there's a lot of Road
cones and Market things and
but not much Happening Now obviously we
found our archaeological
piece of wood
and that's held everything out now I've
just been contacted look and I I know
they're concerned by the businesses
along there and and the weird way you
have to access that so when is work
going to start again and when what's
what's happening there uh so work is
already back underway at that site
um and it was and it was under I'll need
to find out why there was uh nothing
visibly happening on site today
um but the work is back underway
um the archaeological team have been in
they have uh essentially observed and
documented
um the find and then they'll need to
just come in at various different points
as we work around that with the job but
I can find out why there appeared to be
not a lot going on today okay and the
other one that that gets reported back
to me is chair is steadstreet and even
though it's not our work the new pump
station people are asking how long
is that going to go for a zero have we
been told
um and a sort of a date for that
um we don't have the the latest dates
all we receive is and Russell May jump
in here all we receive is a traffic
management plan that essentially puts um
the timeline within which they can do
the work they do come and advise us and
have done of when they were going to put
traffic lights in place and things like
that
um but again we don't have any control
over how quickly they get that work done
simply that they do it in accordance
with the traffic management plan
right okay did Russell have anything he
wanted to add
it's true we can certainly ask the
project Managers from environment South
and to give us an update and produce a
timeline which I think is really what
we're looking for but we continue to ask
them to actually make sure that they
minimize the disruption and I guess
that's why you see periods where they
reduce the traffic for a specific task
and as soon as they can release it to
two lanes they do so so yes that's
part of the longer term process but
happy to go and ask for an updated
timeline so we can have some greater
certainty on it oh look that would be
really good because at the moment it is
just seems for everyone I think they've
built two more pyramids in Egypt since
um this is a really an issue for Steve
he's not here today by the little things
so if Michael can't answer it I'd be
happy to have it come back um and if
she's been raised on me several times
around
um members of the community the
transgender using the toilets at Splash
Palace
and using the female toilets in
particular
so I know there's something worked on
but it'd be helpful to know what the
alternative arrangements are now
yes
through yourself chair um I mean Clark
we're currently in the process of
reviewing what our obligations are into
that and future Solutions but current
temporary solutions we have go put in
place is the one of the parent changing
facilities is being used as a
um transgender changing facility and
we've got the male and female changing
facility in place at the moment so we
are accommodating it within the current
construct of air facilities however we
are looking for what we need to do into
the future and that will be a one of our
long-term plans because it will require
alterations to the facility to enable it
yes just a second request into that so
I'm not familiar with what's in the
parent changing facilities but is that
the ability to have lockers because one
of the issues that was right with me was
the ability of women or children with uh
women with children or just women by
themselves to be confronted by somebody
that's transgender
um and it's so if there's some
facilities I mean they use a locker or a
room they go into as opposed to just
being in the general space
I believe they are separate but I will
need to get Steve to come back and
confirm that but I'm pretty sure they're
separate thank you thank you look I just
wanna
justify my frustration at the stage
three project I got caught at the red
light failure that happened the other
night coming back in and it went through
cycle after cycle after cycle after
cycle
being readed with where I was it was
letting traffic the other way and thank
you for Mr Pearson for taking my like
call and uh and sorting it out and it's
these things I think that really
exasperate the feeling of of things not
happening so you know and that was yes
you should buy a cycle
you could have got it and picked up some
rubbish if you're going from the 19th
Hole of the odotara golf club you could
go the back road now
I was with my wife and my lovely dog
beer returning from my mom could run but
yes you're supposed to appear something
sorry she just to put away with a
Clarity also around that during the
years that I guess the major Peak
traffic and the contractor As I
understood it was having a person who
was mechanic or sort of there was
actually controlling it and it was after
that period of I guess that main Peak
traffic that the equipment had a fault
and which was corrected the contractor
attended pretty quickly and I think the
next day or the day after they actually
had got to a point where they could open
it for two lanes so I guess that's we
are a little bit dependent and and that
is a that is a learning that we actually
need to take on these things do actually
break down sometimes but and actually
the I guess that backup plan of what is
the instruction when it is a red light
now I guess that's the challenge that
you face it if you've got a long stream
of traffic what happens and I guess I
haven't got a magical answer to tell you
what to do with that situation lucky the
chair of infrastructure was stuck second
in the cube with a phone number of the
running manager who responded
immediately so thank you Russell
right so I think the recommendation is
that we receive the activities report
and note the tender for council's Road
Corridor maintenance contract will be
live on the 8th of May 2023. so uh move
Trish seconded partner I'll put those
all those in favor
aye against that is carried um can I
have someone please move were you going
to other exclude move table and seconded
Alan put the motion all those in favor
yes that's carried uh thank you for the
media being here
we are now in public